Recently, we've been predicting changes in graphs based on changes in
equations. So let's work the other way around for a second. Here's the graph of
a function. I'm going to call this graph A. And I'd like us to consider this
our original graph. Now, graph B over here is a transformed version of graph A.
Now, I didn't size these graphs perfectly, so B's a little bit shrunk. But the
only thing that's happening. In order for graph A, to become graph B. Is first,
it's shifted in some direction. Either right, left, up, or down. By some number
of units. And then it's reflected. Either in the x axis. Or in the y axis. I
would like you to feel in the sentence properly. To describe this
transformation, from A to B.